thank always good on the man oh that's
right thank you
haha should call this video before the
fight we have been together for like
almost two years and my impression of
her has been honed over the past five
years I think it's pretty good we have
the same mannerisms it's gonna teach
other sentences all that sentences he's
gonna be so much better because he's so
observant Oh guys I don't know what's up
my name is Zack oh man today is just
nuts tomorrow right I'm Kevin McShane is
a little naval it won't sound like a an
anchorman oh my god I'm so tired I have
so much work to do but I don't know if
I'm ready to go to sleep yet that's
every sentence from her when she gets
really excited she starts slipping a
little bit yeah
fire and she's embarrassed she just
thought oh my gosh when you get like
really excited you kind of almost don't
finish your sentences I'm gonna be a
robot and talk like this and this is my
mechanical voice hey brah yeah hey Bry
you lifting you mad dude you know when
she's drunk that's for sure not cuz
she's like belligerent or anything but
just because the eye is kinda like baby
I got dollars I got bills I can pay for
this I do not care I got money to blow
listen listen I love you so much no spit
no find Jay guys I'm making a big joke
you should laugh and it's like really it
was like weird big personality I'll hear
the words baby a lot like baby hi and
her biggest thing is she talks to
everyone and everyone's her best friend
being a party you'd be like this is my
boyfriend isn't he cute he's the cutest
you guys he's the cutest and then if you
have like two more drinks you're like
yeah here oh we haven't fought really
that's a lie we never fight and then six
months he'd be like back in August this
and I'm like the summer you have this
thinking face that you get if you're
really concentrating you start going
like this I just I just need your
support that one day you'll say things
like for crying out loud or
oh my gosh like oh okay well I mean you
know whatever and this that and the
other thing and if you're drunk cuz I
gotta here
no one Kevin likes to give me lap dances
but then you get the white man's
overbite is like hey you know you like
it oh oh this a face Otis a beta that's
what you forgot long is she don't care
oh well Ned Ned goes crotch first he's
like then a lot like repetitive life and
he was a lot of this then there's a lot
of this what she dances like an
overexcited schoolteacher it's a lot of
and she's dancing she's got there she go
that's half of her dancing is her just
like commentary that's it arioli oh I'm
so good wait I'm actually really proud
of that it's harder than I expected I
think I was more on than I thought I'd
be I nailed it
and I starts like hanging on people like
this I'm not like sloppy finish a drunk
girl why